lily collins earned an emmy nomination
for the hit series emily in paris the
actress and producer narst now stars
rather in a thriller it's called
windfall
collins plays the wife of tech
billionaire jesse plemons and they walk
into a robbery at their vacation home
the robbers played by jason siegel he
tries to get to know the couple
him i've read plenty about
but you i mean you're a mystery so why
don't you start
my favorite color is black
i can tell
what's this tattoo you're getting
removed on your foot
how about you stop looking at my wife's
feet yeah
it was nothing
the tattoo was nothing
that was one of the ugliest tattoos i've
ever seen in my life
yeah i know you've made that pretty
clear
lily collins joins us first on cbs
mornings good morning to you lily
collins
let's talk about this movie because
we've been talking all morning about the
twists and turns and it certainly takes
that
but you're married to a tech billionaire
to put it uh very kindly he's really a
bit of a douche canoe
oh i love that yes yeah good a bit of a
douche canoe
and in the credits when you go when the
credits are ending you're nobody has a
name you're called wife he's called ceo
yes and jason siegel who was funny to
see him playing a bad guy yeah he's
called nobody right what was the
decision-making process not to give any
of the characters a name
well it's a human trait to associate
certain um empathy or sympathy or just
personal
connection to somebody when they have a
name and we wanted an audience not to
have that personal connection right away
and to really feel as though they are
just these singular characters there's
only you know um three of us in most of
the movie and so everyone is flawed
everyone has their reasons and choices
that they made that got them to where
they ended up and to add a name as an
added element of human connection that
we didn't want the audience to it's a
it's a label of how they are perceived
during the movie exactly um now your
character is involved in a very
dark and twisted and i won't give
anything away it's so hard not to your
character is somewhat uh underestimated
throughout this yes yes that's a good
way to what was it like to have that
type of ending without giving anything
well you know it's interesting this is a
character that's very undermined silence
quieted um and underrated almost at the
beginning by these two very heavy
male-driven ego energies and to play a
character like that that is
um
has a trajectory shall we say that ends
up where she does it was an interesting
thing as an actor because you don't want
to just come across as someone that's in
a scene but silent and doesn't it
doesn't have much to do but in those
quiet moments there's so much that she's
digesting and you want to get to the end
and be able to backtrack and have these
moments where the audience can
clue in on certain moments where things
are percolating and she's thinking about
things and to have such a downward
trajectory in an upward spiral and i mix
those words up because it is a
trajectory and a spiral at the same time
it's an interesting thing it's also a
good commentary i think on income
inequality could you talk about that for
a second because this couple they are so
obnoxious especially your husband they
are so obnoxious that when he's
negotiating for the ransom
about the payment that he wants you both
say well that's not enough he asked for
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars you
got you both of you say nope that's not
enough i've never seen anything like
that before so it's laugh out loud funny
in the middle of this drama um yeah you
know there had to be this kind of dark
comedic undertone to something like this
because i think it does keep you on your
toes but it also does speak about the
haves the have-nots the disparity of
wealth and when you're so in that bubble
and in your own world you can be
completely oblivious to someone else's
perspective and there is this sparring
between ceo and wife that you need to
see in order to understand their
relationship or lack of relationship
that leads to where it leads but it
touches on a lot of um different themes
that i think are very relevant to
today's world in a way that is relatable
grounding but also comedic and
outlandish now i think it's safe to say
you were sleeping with a director who
also happens to be your husband now
she's not a [ __ ] that was her you guys
you guys were engaged at the time
we were engaged at the time when you
were filming and so i wondered what it
was like for you because he is your
significant other and he's directing you
in a role were you able to separate this
is my partner my significant other and
this is my director good question
weirdly yeah i there were moments when i
forgot that we were together because the
way in which he directs he's such a
communicative and collaborative director
that is all about how the actor feels
and grounding it in truth and
someone that you feel very safe with an
environment where you're the most
vulnerable and that's what you want in a
life partner and it is what you want as
an actor and your director and he treats
everyone the same and there were very
few of us in the cast and so we all had
a very intimate collaborative experience
that sometimes i would forget that it
was
my charlie as opposed to charlie my
director and um it was so fun charlie
did a good job yeah
got it um you did a good job critics are
saying that this is one of your best
performances thank you what is it like
to hear something like that i honestly
i i attest so much of it to charlie i
mean it there's there's something very
specific that he saw in all of us we all
play against type um but for me
specifically that he saw in in me and
that he got out of me that i haven't
been able to do it
creatively believes in me sometimes
maybe more than i believe in myself to
get somewhere which is really special
again as a spouse and as a director you
want that person to say no you can do
this and to push you creatively so it's
i'm just really proud of all of us
during the pandemic to do something like
this well and it's not a pandemic movie
right a lot of people know you lilly as
uh emily and paris of course ray don who
does my makeup because she watches you
and she says when i watch her it makes
me want to fall in love and wear cute
clothes and go to paris keep in mind ray
don is happily married
that's what you do for people that role
makes people dream and fantasize and
that was what does the character mean to
you
she means that she she's positivity
she's bright bold unapologetic
unapologetically herself and i think at
a time when we all needed laughter and
levity more than ever
the show was able to provide a sense of
escapism and and smiles and that's
therapeutic in its own way and healing
and to be able to heal in a time when we
needed it was a huge gift we get two
more seasons of it yes
something when saturday night live does
a parody what did you think oh my god my
phone's never blown up so much when
peyton manning did that skit i i think i
think more people acknowledged that that
didn't know the show in it like than
i've ever experienced did you ever think
that you know that you would be
recognized by like the number one and i
was like no you know you made it i was
like oh my god wearing a french beret
why not why not so great congratulations
so much and our best to charlie yeah
well done well done
lily collins is on the movie windfall
you can see it right now on netflix and
when i tell you there's a big twist at
the end
there's several twists at the end she's
knockout in it we'll be right back